Каталонія.
Північна Італія включно з Венецією.
Фландрія на півночі Бельгії.
У Європі є чимало регіонів, які прагнуть
незалежності. І саме це може розхитати ЄС.
Це може поширитися, зрости,
стати заразним. І від Європейського Союзу,
який нині складається із 28 країн,
можу почати де-не-де
відпадати частинки, наче шматки від сухого пирога.
З точки зору економіки відокремлення
сепаратистських регіонів може мати важкі наслідки
для відповідних держав-членів ЄС.
Наприклад, внесок Фландрії до ВВП Бельгії
складає майже 60%.
А частка італійських регіонів
Венето і Ломбардії у ВВП країни -
понад третина.
Регіони ЄС з рухом за незалежність
складають понад вісім відсотків
економічної потужності Євросоюзу.
Але коли справа доходить до відокремлення,
залишати ЄС вони не хочуть.
Цікава деталь щодо цих націоналістів,
як-то, приміром, у Каталонії, це те, що вони
проєвропейські націоналісти. На відміну від таких,
як Ле Пен у Франції, вони не хочуть виходити з ЄС.
Вони хочуть залишитися в союзі, але
як окремі держави.
На думку експертів, якщо Каталонія доб’ється
незалежності, то слідом за нею активізуються
і інші регіони.
Та найважливіше, у який саме спосіб буде ухвалене
рішення щодо Каталонії.
Економіка потребує стабільності
та передбачуваності. Якщо боротьба
за незалежність Каталонії буде хаотичною,
неорганізованою та конфліктною, тоді економіка
потерпатиме. Якби це був законний процес, то
Каталонія змогла б вижити як окрема країна.
Наразі ніхто не демонструє ознак компромісу
щодо незалежності сепаратистських регіонів Іспанії.
Тим часом усі європейські регіони
з рухами за незалежність
уважно стежать за розвитком подій навколо Каталонії.
Адже це покаже, які їхні шанси на незалежність.